♪♪
Narrator: IT'S TIME
FOR MAN OF THE MOMENT...
HOW YOU DOIN'?
Narrator: ...MacGYVER.
♪♪
I LIKE THIS THING.
MAYBE I'M GONNA TRY IT OUT.
Narrator: OUR MULLETED HERO
SPRINGS INTO ACTION.
AND PERFECT.
RIGHT THERE.
MATCHING THE CLIP,
HE DIRECTS THE DUMP TRUCK
TO UNLOAD EIGHT CUBIC YARDS,
OR 32,000 POUNDS, OF WET CEMENT.
Jamie:
IT'S COMING OUT.
IT LOOKS KIND OF LIKE A COW
TAKING A DUMP.
♪♪
[ LAUGHS ]
IT REALLY DOES LOOK LIKE A COW
TAKING A DUMP,
AND I'VE NEVER EVEN SEEN THAT.
WOW.
Narrator: IT'LL TAKE 30 MINUTES
TO FILL HER UP,
BUT THERE'S A PROBLEM.
WHAT'S UP?
LOOK AT
THE BAG OF EXPLOSIVES
THAT CAME OUT
FROM UNDER THE TABLE.
OH [BLEEP]
DESPITE
JAMIE'S PRECAUTIONS...
WHAT DO WE DO?
WHAT CAN WE DO?
...40-ODD POUNDS
OF PRIMED-TO-EXPLODE DYNAMITE
IS DANGEROUSLY DETACHED.
IT HAS TO BE SECURED --
AND FAST.
WE CAN CUT A BIGGER HOLE
AND CRAWL THROUGH THIS.
IRONICALLY, THEY'VE GOT TO
MacGYVER THE SITUATION.
WITH THE CEMENT
ALREADY 12 INCHES DEEP,
THEY CAN'T GO THROUGH THE DOORS.
I'M SORRY, BUT I HAVE TO
TAKE OFF THE MacGYVER WIG.
Narrator:
THE CEMENT IS RAPIDLY SETTING.
THE SUN IS HEATING
THE TRUCK INTERIOR
TO A STIFLING 150 DEGREES.
[ GROANS ] [BLEEP]
AND THERE'S AN UNEXPLODED BOMB
TO BE MANHANDLED.
HOO!
ALL RIGHT, I'M IN.
♪♪
[ GROANS ]
THAT FEELS [BLEEP]
Narrator: ALL IN A DANGEROUS
DAY'S WORK FOR THE MYTHBUSTERS.
I JUST REMEMBERED THIS IS
40-SOME-ODD POUNDS OF TNT.
GONNA HANDLE IT GENTLY.
ALL RIGHT.
Narrator: TO MAKE SURE
THEY MATCH THE CLIP...
THANK YOU.
...THE LOOSE BAG HAS TO BE
SUBMERGED UNDER THE CONCRETE.
SO ADAM BOXES IT IN, AND WITH
SOME 2X4, SCREWS IT DOWN.
LET'S CLEAR THE AREA!
LET'S START PUMPIN'!
Narrator: MacGYVER IS BACK
ON TRACK TO SAVE THE DAY.
Adam: IN THE CLIP, IT LOOKS LIKE
ALMOST NOTHING HAPPENS AT ALL.
OKAY, WET CONCRETE EXPLOSION
IN THREE...
LIKE THERE'S A BOOM
AND THE TRUCK JUMPS
AND THERE'S A LITTLE FIRE,
AND THAT'S IT.
...TWO...
THAT WOULD BE
THE MOST IDEAL OUTCOME.
...ONE.
WOW.
♪♪
THAT TOTALLY
WENT OFF,
AND ALL THE DUMMIES
ARE STANDING.
♪♪
IT WORKED.
[BLEEP]
THAT WORKED GANGBUSTERS.
IT DID.
Narrator:
IT'S AN ASTONISHING RESULT.
AS PER THE CLIP, THE EXPLOSION
WAS ALMOST COMPLETELY SMOTHERED.
THAT WAS AMAZING.
I'M COMPLETELY BLOWN AWAY.
Jamie: LET'S FACE IT.
SOME OF THE STUFF WE'VE SEEN ON
"MacGYVER" IS DOWNRIGHT SILLY.
BUT THIS ONE TURNED OUT
TO BE, ACTUALLY,
DARNED IMPRESSIVE.